des choses effectivement qui s'étales
qui sont archéologues étudiants ou
professionnels néophytes ou passionnés
ils se sont réunis pour débattre
réfléchir informés mais surtout rendre
la profession plus interactive
l'archéocamp propose 6 ateliers pour
fouiller et mettre au jour l'avenir de
l'archéologie une méthode participative
le public a choisi sur place les thèmes
abordés dans la journée là j'écris le
thème d'atelier que j'aimerais voir
aborder cet après-midi donc voilà la
pédagogie que faire pour pour enseigner
aux gens à lutter contre le pillage ou
avoir différemment
le pillage pour lutter contre
le pillage de thème a bien été retenu
l'occasion de sensibiliser d'éclairer
puisque chercheur de trésor comme de
reliques est un métier bien encadré et
le détecteur de métaux un outil qui
nécessite autorisation préalable la
démarche de la personne a acheté un
détecteur de métaux et avant tout de
rentabiliser l'achat de sa machine à
l'effet de collection ou de revente et
d'objets anciens également donc le rêve
de trouver un trésor le tout en essayant
de dissimuler donc à la loi donc à
l'ensemble du patrimoine à la
connaissance de notre patrimoine les 10
vestiges mobilier retrouver des vols qui
touchent à la fois les sites
archéologiques mais aussi plus largement
l'ensemble des termes en sondés des
fouilles clandestine qui peuvent
détériorer les trouvailles mais surtout
privés de toute contextualisation ce
patrimoine historique non renouvelable